let's talk a little bit about what I'll
call the plot ski plan because it came
from my friend Todd blood ski but I
think it's a good plan but let's think
about a little bit of its repercussions
and see if it's more or less likely to
actually work well first of all and you
know I throw out in the last video of 50
banks maybe that's logistically
difficult instead of having 50 banks
with 14 billion of initial capital maybe
you do five banks with one hundred forty
billion dollars of initial capital but
the point being is that you should have
more than one bank it shouldn't be too
big to fail and and you should try to
instill some type of competition there
but because they have pristine balance
sheets all of these banks are going to
be able to lever ten to one which we
know isn't crazy Merrill Lynch and and
Morgan Stanley and all the life been
leveraging up 30 and 41 so 10 - what is
normal for Bank and frankly they're
probably going to be able to attract a
lot more you know we said of you know
foreign governments probably willing to
lend to them the private sector is
willing to lend to them a lot of these
are commercial banks which means that
they can take deposits a lot of people
are going to be willing to essentially
put their money with this bank because
it has a clean balance sheet and it is
essentially owned it'll be owned
individually by the American people and
will have this federal backstop above
and beyond the the FDIC insurance limits
and all of that although I do like the
the one provision to increase the FDIC
caps and maybe I'll do a the insurance
caps on on deposits but I'll actually be
able to attract a lot of deposits from
everyday people they'll feel safer with
these these banks so in terms of whether
you'll be able to capitalize these banks
and lever up ten to one I don't think
there's an issue there then there's a
question will it solve the fundamental
problem of of keeping credit markets
flowing to those people that needs to
keep credit - well we already said that
it'll have no trouble being able to have
access to funds above and beyond how
much the government capitalizes it with
it'll be able to track deposits it'll be
able to attract investment from from the
private sector and from from
international money especially with this
five-year government backstop so it will
be able to essentially put ten times as
money back into the system so if you
take seven hundred billion dollars
collectively you'll be able to this will
introduce seven to ten times as much so
so seven trillion dollars
of new loans seven trillion of new loans
so there's seven trillion of I mean
that's literally half of of the American
GDP I mean you might argue that is too
much that might that might provide too
much credit and it might go from you
know thawing to overheating credit
markets so then you might say well if
seven trillion is too much liquidity
well why don't we just reduce this
number a little bit why instead of
saying 700 billion why don't you make it
a hundred billion right because then 100
billion if you do ten banks with ten
billion each so you introduce 100 let me
just say 100 billion they all lever up
because it's all new its new liabilities
and new assets clean balance sheets
it'll introduce one trillion dollars of
new loans that it can go put to work for
people building factories and doing real
things and because they're incentive is
not to bail out their friends it's not
to help out the companies they used to
work for the companies that are donating
to them in some way or contributing to
them or promising jobs in some way it
won't go this trillion dollars is not
going to go to buy assets at higher
prices than they should you know I could
go to buy assets at discount prices if
the new managers of these banks do see a
good return but most probably they'll
invest it in areas of the economy where
they do see a positive return on
investment and it'll and and I what one
person had 10 minutes a day wouldn't
introducing all of this liquidity into
the into the financial system whether
it's 7 trillion or 1 trillion
wouldn't that lead to hyperinflation and
I'll probably do a whole series on
inflation I I think there's a lot of
misunderstanding around it in general if
anyone makes a positive investment so if
if I have a dollar and I make it an
investment where it generates a dollar
20 of benefit that by definition that by
definition is not inflationary because I
had a dollar in the world I had a dollar
in the world and I created a dollar 20
of wealth so actually the pie gets
bigger a good way to think about
inflation I'll do a lot about this
because it is kind of it is a very
abstract concept let's say that this is
the pie of goods and services in the
world or let's say just say in a country
right
goods and services goods and services in
a year you could say it's our GDP or
however you want to measure goods and
services in a year in a year right
that's the goods and services in a year
and let's say I have another pool of the
amount of money there isn't in a given
year
so money and the money supply is an
interesting thing because it's not just
dependent on the amount of physical
coins or dollars it also is a function
of how quickly those transact and how
much leverage there is in the system so
you can actually have a whole economy
where everyone just has one dollar bill
but every time someone needs something
from someone else they exchange that one
dollar bill so that one dollar bill gets
used you know fifteen trillion times a
year so you'd actually have fifteen
trillion dollars of money because the
velocity would be so high but anyway
let's just say that this is the pool of
money if this pool the pool of money
grows faster than the actual goods and
services and the actual productive
capacity of that country then you have
inflation so if this circle is grows
faster than this one you have inflation
if this circle grows faster than this
circle you have deflation you have the
same or you have some amount of money
representing more goods and services so
goods and services actually become
cheaper and the the problem that we're
talking about right now this credit
crisis this is a problem of deleveraging
where the government injects a dollar
into the this current broken banking
system and instead of that dollar you
know you you let nor the normal system
is you lend a dollar to a bank so you
lend one dollar to a bank and then let's
say this is the Fed right this is how
they inject liquidity they lend a dollar
to a bank let me draw a bank here then
that Bank has to keep it can only lever
ten to one so it essentially it has to
keep in reserve ten cents of that dollar
but then it lends 90 cents to somebody
else to another Bank right then that
other Bank has to keep 10% of that so it
lends 81 cents to someone else and then
that someone else can lend whatever 81
times 0.9 is so I know seventy something
cents to someone else but you get the
idea that in normal functioning the
normal functioning
banking system $1 injection of the
system has this multiplier effect so it
actually creates a lot of money and
that's what if people are implicitly
talking about when they talk about the
printing press but what's going on right
now is the Fed lends $1 to Bank a but
Bank a is so scared it's so scared that
it doesn't lend out to anyone else it
just keeps that dollar because right now
their main priority isn't to try to get
a little bit of incremental interest on
whatever money they have their main
priority is survival so that dollar just
goes into a black hole and so that's
what the feds frustration is it keeps
lending money into the system but that
money keeps disappearing and actually as
the economy slows the velocity of money
is going to slow down as well so the
main problem when you have a credit
crisis and when you have a recession is
actually the money supply shrinks the
amount of goods and services
probably shrinks as well but the money
supply shrinks even more so your main
problem is deflation and that's why you
know that was the main problem in in the
Great Depression and that was the main
problem in the Japanese crisis and you
know you Ben Bernanke he's written
papers about this and he's like well you
can always you can always cure deflation
by printing money and dropping money
from a helicopter well to some degree
that's what they've already been trying
to do they've already been the feds been
willing to take you know really take
pretty large credit risks on bank and
lending money into the system but the
problem is is if this multiplier effect
is disappearing at a faster rate than
you are dropping money from a helicopter
you still have deflation right before
when you not only levered a lot people
lever ten to one you let them lever 30
to one and 40 to one every dollar you
put into the system became $40 that it
was given to someone else and then they
could lever up so you had this huge
explosion of money and frankly the only
reason why we didn't have inflation I
mean in the last 5-10 years we had this
huge explosion of money and the only
reason why didn't it didn't at least in
measurable inflation show up is that
week on the other side of the equation
you had all of this new productive
capacity come online in China and India
and so manufactured goods got a lot
cheaper but in things that were not
manufactured goods like commodities like
homes you had this huge
asset inflation or even college tuition
or healthcare things that are dependent
on on American labor it became hugely
expensive in this because you had this
huge huge infusion of you know that
there's there's different ways to
measure money but the broadest indicator
which is called m3 and I know I'm kind
of going out of the domain but I'll make
a bunch of videos on this the broadest
indicator m3 which the government
stopped officially reporting exploded
because there's so much leverage in the
system now things are the exact opposite
is happening the leverage is
disappearing from the system there's no
lending to each other everyone is going
from 31 to 30 levels to one to ten
leverage so money is actually
disappearing the system the velocity is
slowing this is shrinking but this is
shrinking more no matter what the Fed is
doing and frankly this new $700 $700
bailout I personally think this is the
helicopter that Ben Bernanke always
talked about using and whenever you're
going to drop money from a helicopter
the question is where do you drop it and
they think they should drop it into an
already broken banking system the point
of this video in the last is maybe you
should just drop it into a new banking
system or maybe you just drop it into
everyone's pockets and and and see what
happens and you let new banks form where
they can anyway that's all for this
video I know it's a little bit rambling
but hopefully you'll learn a little bit
see in the next video